Das ist wirklich Frankenstein-like: Ein Forschungsteam
aus der Schweiz hat jetzt das Erbgut einer
wirklich ganz neuen, künstlichen Bakterienart
erschaffen!
Zuvor hatten die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler diese Lebensform im Computer
entworfen.
“Caulobacter ethensis-2.0” - so lautet
also der Name des weltweit ersten komplett
am Computer erzeugten Genom eines Lebewesens!
“. Wie bitte?
Damit kommen wir der wahnwitzigen Vision ein
gutes Stück näher, künstlich maßgeschneiderte
Lebensformen zu erschaffen.
Ob das wirklich gut ist?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Der Fachbereich der synthetischen Biologie
hat einen großen Traum: Künstliche Lebensformen
erschaffen, die maßgeschneidert sind!
Und fest steht: Wir sind auf einem guten Weg
dahin, diese wahnwitzige Vision Wirklichkeit
werden zu lassen!
Vor neun Jahren (2010) fing alles an.
Damals gelang es, das Erbgut eines Bakteriums
1:1 nachzubauen und es dann in lebende Mikroben
einzupflanzen.
Der zweite entscheidende Erfolg bestand darin,
das erste synthetische Chromosom einer Hefe,
zu konstruieren.
Das, was jetzt aber einem Forschungsteam aus
der Schweiz gelang, überragt das alles noch
einmal.
Denn die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
haben das synthetische Bakteriengenom nicht
nur von ihren natürlichen Vorbildern kopiert
und gekürzt, sondern es - zumindest teilweise-
neu entworfen.
Somit handelt es sich also um das weltweit
erste komplett am Computer erzeugte Genom
eines Lebewesens!
Der Name: “Caulobacter ethensis-2.0”.
Festzuhalten ist allerdings, dass bisher nur
das Genom existiert, also ein sehr großes
DNA-Molekül.
Der dazugehörige Organismus existiert noch
nicht.
Die Genom-Version von C.ethensis-2.0 basiert
auf dem Genom des Bakteriums “Caulobacter
crescentus”, das überall auf der Welt im
Süßwasser vorkommt.
Es dient der Wissenschaft oft als Modellorganismus,
da es harmlos ist, keine Krankheiten verursacht
und mittlerweile schon gut untersucht ist.
Insgesamt 4.000 Gene umfasst das Bakteriengenom
natürlicherweise.
Jedoch sind nur 680 Gene sind notwendig, damit
dieses Bakterium im Labor überleben kann
- das hatten frühere Studien gezeigt.
Anders als die bisherigen Experimente in diesem
Zusammenhang kopierte das Forschungsteam aus
der Schweiz das bakterielle Genom von “Caulobacter
crescentus” aber eben nicht 1:1, sondern
veränderte es mit Hilfe eines Computer-Algorithmus.
Die DNA-Abfolge des Genoms wurde dabei zwar
nur minimal verändert, doch die Gesamtheit
der Veränderungen ist enorm.
Mehr als ein Sechstel der 800.000 DNA-Bausteine
sind im künstlichen Genom im Vergleich zu
dem natürlichen “Minimalgenom” verändert.
Dazu Beat Christen, der an der Studie beteiligt
war: “In unserem Genom ist die Abfolge der
DNA-Bausteine neu und gegenüber der ursprünglichen
Abfolge nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen; die biologische
Funktion auf Ebene der Proteine bleibt jedoch
dieselbe”.
Insgesamt wurden 236 Genom-Teilstücke synthetisiert
und wieder zusammengesetzt.
Eine komplizierte Angelegenheit.
Dazu der beteiligte Forscher und Bruder von
Beat, Matthias Christen: “Nicht immer ist
die Synthese dieser Teilstücke einfach.
Denn DNA-Moleküle haben nicht nur die Fähigkeit,
sich an andere DNA-Moleküle zu heften, sie
können je nach Baustein- Abfolge auch Schlaufen
und Knäuel mit sich selbst bilden, was die
Herstellung erschweren oder verunmöglichen
kann.”
Am Ende entstand so ein komplett synthetisches
Bakteriengenom.
Auch, wenn es auf dem Genom des Süßwasserbakteriums
Caulobacter crescentus fußt, sind die Abweichungen
zum Original so stark, dass diese Kreation
als eine neue Art betrachtet werden kann.
Das synthetische Erbgut von “Caulobacter
ethensis 2.0” ist sogar offiziell in der
US-Datenbank des National Center for Biotechnology
Information (NCBI) eingetragen.
Erste Tests haben gezeigt, dass das umgeschriebene
Genom noch nicht zu 100 Prozent perfekt ist.
Den bisherigen Experimente zufolge sind nur
rund 580 der 680 künstlichen Gene funktionsfähig.
Doch die Fachleute sind optimistisch, mit
diesem Wissen den Algorithmus verbessern zu
können.
So soll dann bald eine “voll funktionsfähige
Genom-Version-3.0” entwickelt werden, so
das Forschungsteam.
Und nicht nur das - die Experten denken groß!
Dazu Matthias Christen: “Auch wenn die derzeitige
Genom-Version noch nicht perfekt ist, so zeigt
unsere Arbeit dennoch, dass biologische Systeme
so einfach aufgebaut sind, dass wir sie in
Zukunft am Computer nach unseren Zwecken definieren
und anschließend bauen können”.
Heißt also im Klartext, dass es wohl nicht
mehr lange Zeit dauern wird, bis aus einem
solchen Genom funktionsfähige bakterielle
Zellen hergestellt werden können.
Und diese neue Technologie aus der Schweiz
ist sehr effizient und zudem kostengünstig.
Laut Angaben der Fachgruppe waren Herstellungskosten
von nur rund 105.000 Euro (120.000 Schweizer
Franken) notwendig.
Das Ganze birgt also ein extrem großes Potential
für die Biotechnologie.
Denn solche synthetischen Genome könnten
dazu beitragen Mikroben zu produzieren, die
dann wiederum nützliche Bio-Moleküle erzeugen.
Beispielsweise Impfstoffe, Vitamine oder Medikamente.
Ein großer Pluspunkt: Die Technologie ist
nicht nur auf “Caulobacter” anwendbar,
sondern auf alle Mikroorganismen.
Doch klar ist auch, dass diese Art von Forschung
enorm umstritten ist und viele ethische Fragen
aufwirft.
Denn das Erschaffen solcher künstlicher Lebensformen
ist ein erheblicher Eingriff in die Evolution
und in die Natur.
Und niemand weiß, welche langfristigen Folgen
das für uns alle haben könnte.
Die große Frage, die es zu beantworten gilt,
lautet: Wer darf wann und zu welchen Zwecken
eine solche Technologie anwenden?
Gibt es unsichtbare Tiere?
spannendes video von NeugierZone, also anklicken,
anschauen und Neugierzone abonnieren!